hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
optical genome mapping unrivaled
structural variant detection for cancer
research
and precision medicine i am marie stone
of lab roots and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
bio nano genomics to learn more
visit bionanogenomics.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box
and click send all questions will be
answered
via email following today's presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen
to obtain your credits i'd like to now
welcome our speaker
dr yannick delpu head of clinical
affairs
bio nano genomics and dr darren ben
finlay scientific director tumor
analysis research assistant professor
sanford burnham predicts medical
discovery institute
dr del poo you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone i'm janine delpu and it's
my pleasure to welcome you to this uh
binance workshop session to discuss what
optical mapping
can offer for the study and
characterization of cancer sample
qr codes will be displayed during this
presentation to take you to
relevant publications or webinars so you
might want to have your
smartphone ready among all
biological tissues cancer is probably
the most
complicated to interrogate genome
instability constitutes
a major challenge for the
characterization of such a sample by
current technologies
and add to that the high cellular
heterogeneity
the presence of many clones bearing
different genetic alteration
this explains the limitation of ngs
and how it led to a lack of
understanding of the role of
structural variation in cancer which
remains
largely overlooked today
and that is very easy to understand when
you take into account that
two-thirds of the human genome is
repetitive making it
extremely challenging for algorithms to
reassemble the reads in these regions
and the consequence is that many
structural variants will remain
invisible to these technologies
getting reads of several dozens of
kilobases using long-range sequencing
is an improvement for sure but when you
deal with
heterogeneous samples to cover this key
when you want to address some highly
heterogeneous tumors
with a highly clonal population what's
the point of spending tens of thousands
of dollars
in sequencing if you just get a fraction
of the infra
information you seek
the way our technology works isn't based
on sequencing and can be compared to
karyotyping but at a much higher
resolution
with car typing what you have on the
left chromosomes are stained in a way
you can distinguish a pattern
of bands that is unique throughout the
genome with a band roughly every
five megabases or so and any abnormality
in this labeling pattern would indicate
the presence
of a chromosomal alteration
the same way with optical genome mapping
a pattern of labels is uh is applied
throughout the genome
at this time with one label every 5 kb
on average
and will be scanned and analyzed
automatically by the sapphire system
and similarly to a cairo typing any
abnormality in this labeling pattern
would indicate the presence
of a chromosomal alteration
here there is no culturing no
amplification no denaturation no
fish brome needed
and this is how it works on the left bar
of the screen you can see that
electrophoretic cycles are applied to
the dna that will be
linearized and elongated in hundreds of
thousands of nano channels in parallel
and that allows the acquisition of a
massive amount of data
by running the instrument a bit longer
you can increase the yield
to coverage levels that are simply out
of reach
of any long-range sequencing technology
and this you can do
at no extra cost on the right panel
you can see the the raw data generated
with the
the dna counter stain in blue and the
green labels
uh as the the green dots you can see
here
another major difference with the
long-range sequencing is the size of the
molecule we
image and there are both 200 kb so we
even have the luxury to disregard
any molecule smaller than 150 kb for our
analysis
so we combine all you need to address
complex cancer samples
long rate information at high coverage
and for a few hundred dollars per sample
the workflow is extremely simple
you extract the dna using our kits to
obtain ultra high molecular weight
dna this dna is labeled
with our enzyme called dle1 and counter
stain and this is where the specific
labeling pattern
is applied genome-wide the stained dna
is then
simply loaded on the chip where the nano
channels are engraved
and from there everything is automatic
the dna molecules
are imaged aligned together
based on the on the labeling pattern to
create a consensus map that we call an
optical map we also measure the coverage
genome-wide to detect any large gain and
losses in the genetic material
and ultimately the sample map in blue
is compared to reference in green this
can be the
adjacent tissue a control cell line or
simply a reference like a
hd19 or a g38 and it
is this step of map comparison that will
identify
any deviation in the labeling pattern
that indicates the presence of a
structural variant
this is how we represent the map
alignment we always
represent the reference in green and the
sample map in blue here you can see a
deletion
and an insertion and we can detect that
by
measuring the shrinking or the
increasing and the distance
between the labels compared to the
reference
the same way we can detect repeat
expansion like this we do not need the
repeat unit to be labeled
we can detect duplication where this
pattern of label from the reference
is found duplicated here and over there
translocation when your map aligns to
two different genomic locations
and inversion and again we can detect
any large
variation in a copy number by looking at
the coverage
you can visualize your cancer genome
in our software called access and we
represent the results under the form of
a circus plot but let me actually take
you
to the live instance of axis you do have
the uh
cytobands on the outside corresponding
to
each region of each chromosome the
dots are representing a structural
variants that are identified by this map
alignment
the color code correspond to insertion
deletion inversion duplications
copy numbers are shown here with two
unemployees identified in this sample
and translocations are the pink lines
uh at the center here you do have an
intra-chromosomal
translocation and every time you will
click on an event
the map will open to show you the
details of these um
structural variants so here we do have
an insertion
of 6kb that is absent from
a control database that is directly
embedded into our software
and allow you to filter the vast
majority of the polymorphic variants you
can find in a sample
and these variants overlap with the clc
a4 gene
and here are shown the different uh
structural variation classes which are
detected by a
optical mapping so we just saw a whole
chromosome changes with
monosomies and and trisomy's cnvs
whether they are
terminal or interstitial duplications
for which we
also give you the the insertion side of
the duplicated fragments and its
orientation
information that are missing from array
approaches
insertions inversions pericentric and
paracentric
and of course no problem to detect um
balanced or unbalanced events like
translocations and we can detect these
events down to one percent early
fraction
thanks to our high coverage and this
automatically
and genome-wide we can detect of course
repeat our expansion and contraction
and while we outperform ngs for the
detection of a structural variation
there is still some complementarity
between the two approaches as we do not
provide you atg and cs because we are
not sequencing based
so single nucleotide variants and very
small indels of a few base pair will be
reported by sequencing
well this performance of optical mapping
to detect variants missed by
ngs and long-range sequencing in
particular can be observed in results
from a recent publication from the
human genome sv consortium
in a well characterized cell line not
highly rearranged as a leukemia sample
could be for example
the sequencing based method based on
attack biohi-fi
means about one-fourth of the variance
identified by binance
and many of these svs that were missed
overlapped with the complex regions of
the genome that can cause
macrodeletion or micro duplication
syndromes for example
the publication did classify some svs
as uh detected by uh by these
sequencing based methods but upon
further analysis however
most of these variants were in fact
identified by optical mapping but simply
classified differently and overall less
than two percent
of the large variants detected by pac
bio were actually missed by
optical mapping so we provide the entire
workflow for the
genome analysis of a cancer sample that
includes this sapphire genome imager
which will
scan the dna the chip on which the nano
channels are engraved
the chemistry to extract and label the
dna
and of course the software the access
software i just showed you
that is free and that you can download
directly from our website we also
provide data sets if you want to play
with
but given its uh unique capabilities
uh optical mapping is playing a central
role in generating results that redefine
our understanding of cancer
in fundamental and translational
research whether it is to uh
well study key mechanisms of
carcinogenesis
to characterize cancer models or trended
find new biomarkers
and this opens new avenues of for
clinical applications
for the identification of actionable
events and also for the modernization of
current diagnostic methods
so let's dive into what we can offer for
the elucidation of
fundamental questions in cancer research
before moving
moving to our value proposition in
translational research and precision
medicine
the major cellular pathways
are known to be altered in cancer and
their understanding is necessary to
identify new biomarkers and develop new
drugs for
personalized medicine or patient
monitoring
dna methylation is one of them and
undergoes tremendous changes during
carcinogenesis that
entirely redesigns the gene expression
profile in cancer cells
and recent work from the tel aviv
university described
a method to interrogate the methylone by
differentially labeling cpgs
on top of the genome-wide labeling
pattern applied by the dla enzyme
that we use for sv detection and the
bottom panel
describes the methylation status at the
single molecule level
of the tpp 53 region which is
and its neighboring enhancers
and this uh exciting work has potential
applications whether it is to uh
identify new epigenetic changes and new
patterns
at low elite frequency in cancer for
biomarker discovery for example
to monitor the efficacy of
de-methylating drugs that are commonly
used
in leukemia treatment and also to
develop new compounds
directly targeting dna methylation
dna replication is also a major target
for
a new generation of drugs in
personalized medicines
for example being able to monitor
replication for progression
allows to understand the replication
timing
in genomes identify fragile sites
but also assess the efficacy of drugs
targeting
a dna replication and dna repair and
this can be done by
incorporating fluorescent nucleotide in
life cells to label
replicating dna on top of the dle1
labeling pattern that we apply on the
genome and these two map
replication fork progression genome-wide
and here this has been used to measure
the
replication timing on chromosome 20
as you can see on this figure
but fundamental science is mostly about
laying the foundations the the first
stones in our
understanding of completely uncharted
territories and
extra chromosomal dna illustrates this
perfectly it's an obscure dna structure
displaying a massive oncogene
amplification but its
structure its effect on gene regulation
and its role in cancer
in general is completely unknown
and ngs alone cannot extrapolate any
structure because the reads are too
short
and the optical maps can be used to
scaffold
these reads and make sense of this ngs
data
optical mapping and the computational
analysis of
whole genome sequencing were used in
this study
in combination to demonstrate the
structure
and make sense of circular ec dna
sequence
for the first time
beyond these applications to study the
basic mechanisms in carcinogenesis
a profound understanding of the genomic
rearrangements
occurring in cancer cells whether they
are
study models or patient biopsies is
paramount
to improve diagnostic methods developing
new drugs
and improved patient care and by nano
excels
in this domain and let me focus now on
the detection
and the resolution of structure
variation in cancer
and how patients can benefit from it
many cancer study models are established
and characterized and associated with a
specific genetic defects that help to
understand the development
and evolution of this cancer but because
of the
limitation of ngs and cytogenetic
approaches
on tumor tissues it is clear today that
a lot of
genetic alteration remains to be
discovered
and that our understanding of these
modals is
by far incomplete with the certainty to
identify new biomarkers or therapeutic
targets
so in a an effort to better characterize
juvenile menoma models the group of
david johnson the career institute in
paris
used hi-c rna sequencing and optical
mapping
to identify structural variation leading
to fusion genes
and over 1000 translocations were
predicted by high c
data in the two models they used mp41
and mp46
but only 50 could be a cross-reference
with their whole genome sequencing data
and none could be validated down the
road
illustrating the issue of false positive
calling
and the burden of data creation when
working from
sequencing data
the rna sequencing approach is pretty
heavy
it's identified over 300 fusions using a
combination
of five algorithm and extensive data
creation
and only those called by at least two
algorithms and in two
independent replicates were considered
solid
14 were kept for validation all of them
found by
optical genome mapping without the need
of a complex binding
in bioinformatic pipeline here and
they could be further characterized i
think this example really
illustrate the simplicity of optical
mapping and how we can tackle the
identification of fusions from the dna
while providing more information than
rna sequencing
so here optical mapping detected a
tandem duplication at this locus
you have this sequence here in the
reference that
actually aligns in the sample map over
here
but also over there this leading to
a specific fusion between the akaten
gene fusing with the mpk
gene over there this was independently
identified
by optical mapping from the dna
confirmed the fusion detected by
rna sequencing but on top of the fusion
detection
optical mapping provided the mechanism
leading to this event
which is a tremendously important
information
so the take-home message here is that
you can identify
any fusion in a genome without
information needed about the fusion
partner
and you can interrogate any region such
as
igh which is notoriously difficult to
deal with by rna sequencing
and this even if your event is present
at lower limit fraction because we
provide a coverage to do so
[Music]
but now i would like to switch gear and
look at more
complex variants as i mentioned earlier
our conception of the role and nature of
structural variation is largely biased
due to the technical limitation of ngs
technologies
beyond simple variants like deletion
duplication translocation inversions
complex structural variation like
chromothrypsis
chromoplexy or templated insertion
chains tic
can cause multiple dna junction in
distinct
topologies and by sequencing thousands
of
cancer genomes new complex sv patterns
have been identified but resolving their
exact structure
is not always possible from ngs data
you can see here a structure called
pirgo pirgo means tower in greek and it
corresponds to a
low junction copy number hotspots it has
been identified specifically
in patient with ovarian cancer you have
at the bottom evidence from the
ngs data of duplication but the
structure
of the event cannot be deducted and this
nested structure you can see here was
resolved
thanks to optical genome mapping one
allele
is actually bearing all the alteration
in the background of a normal allele
with a copy number of five
analyzing these patterns of duplication
with optical mapping is essential
because it reports
not only on the contiguity of the lost
sign but also
the order of the fragments so by
combining
optical mapping and ngs you can
reconstruct
extremely complex events and it is
important
as these new sv classes can cluster
tumors
and identify subgroups of patients as
associated with a
dna repair defect and proof prognosis
and this of course
paves the way to improvements in patient
management
i just mentioned tic so templated
insertion chains
it is a complex sv class that happens to
be associated with a
specific signature in hepatocellular
carcinoma
you can trace back this signature to
patients that develop
this liver cancer due to an infection by
hepatitis b virus that integrates
near a cycling gene and this causes a
complete deregulation of the cell cycle
and replication stress but resolving tic
from ngs data alone isn't possible
because the reads are too short all you
can do
is make a hypothesis with two different
models here
whether it is a chromosome three
segments
from here inserted into a chromosome 1
or a chromosome 1 segment inserted into
a chromosome 3.
and because optical mapping can
completely reconstruct the region with
single molecules
spanning hundreds of kb you can
unambiguously resolve this event
and see here that it is
here in the sample map a piece of
chromosome 1
here that inspired in the context of a
chromosome 3
validating the second possibility
so identifying simple and complex
structure variation is always a
challenge with ngs as we just saw
but the determination of a complex
structural
signature for patient stratification
takes it to another level
and in the same cohorts the
automatically generated
by nano results were sufficient to
cluster patients
based on the presence of replication
stress
due to the deregulation of the cell
cycle following
hpv infection and these patients
harbored
a lot more um chromosomal instability
and you can see at the center
the tremendous amounts of
inter-chromosomal translocation
in addition to uh tendon duplication and
insertion that are reported here
slightly differently from the circle
spot that we generate
and this cluster is different from the
patient without
this hpv insertion where these patients
show way less
chromosomal instability and this has
exciting potential in term of patient
stratification
and identification of subgroups that can
correspond to a particular
that can respond sorry to a particular
therapy like parp inhibitors
and again this doesn't require a complex
bioinformatic pipeline the circles plots
that are automatically generated allow
you to cluster these patients
the same way in head and neck cancer hpv
insertion can cause extensive
chromosomal rearrangement as well
and the circus plots can cluster
patients into two group
the patient with an episomal form so not
integrated that will display minimal
level of
chromosomal instability from those with
an
integrated form that will harbor a
tremendous amount of
recombination and translocation as you
can see
on these circles plots
and from this structural signature
obtained from our map alignment
dr james brooch reconstituted the
complex events
triggering triggered by hpv insertion
represented on these cartoons you have
here
in one sample this hpv insertion that
will trigger
a duplication with hpv at the junction
between the duplicated fragments in this
sample
it will trigger a triplication of this
of this fragment over there but it can
also lead to more complex rearrangement
with here
a translocation between chromosome 11
and 8
with hpv at the fusion between these two
chromosomes
and the most extensive rearrangement
here
with a focal amplification
of that region mediated by hpv
followed by the duplication of these
neighboring fragments
so the take-home message here is that
having single molecules of hundreds of
kb's
to entirely reconstitute highly
rearranged loss size opens the the
possibility
completely out of reach of long-range
sequencing whether it is to make sense
of
ngs data to find new svs or biomarkers
or to assemble complex structural
signature
but how does it apply to the field of
prism
precision medicine this is what we will
discuss
in the last part of this workshop and on
that note i would like to
hand it over to dr darren finley
dr finlay is a research associate
professor and director
of tumor analysis at some southern
burnham in la jolla california
he is a cell biologist with a broad
interest in oncology and drug
sensitivities
and has been stratifying responsive uh
patient-derived cancers based on genomic
features
including structural variants using the
sapphire system
so dr findlay the flow is yours
that introduction and as yannick said
i'm dr darren finley and i'm from san
talk today is going to be talking about
the use of optical genome mapping
to uncover novel structural variants in
leukemias
and how we can associate these
structural variants with drug
sensitivities
these are my disclosures
so just a brief introduction to acute
myeloid leukemia which is the main focus
of my presentation today leukemias in
general
are actually increasing in prevalence
over the last 20 years
which is probably due to an aging
population
and acute more like leukemia is not a
very prevalent disease there's only
about 21 to 22
000 new cases a year in the united
states however it is a major killer
more than 50 percent of those people
will die
so some patients do respond to standard
chemotherapy which is
a cytarabine a dna analog
and also a alkylating agent which is
usually a member of the rubison's donor
rubison
i explicitly mentioned that because i'm
going to show an example of that later
some patients do respond to the standard
of care somewhere
30 to 35 percent however they almost all
relapse
and the only cure for acute modal
leukemia is bone marrow transplantation
where possible
so there's a major unmet need to
identify new or extant drugs
but also to identify patient populations
that will be responsive
to these drugs so for our preliminary
studies we have analyzed nine
samples we've actually analyzed more
than 20 now but our initial studies is
just going to be focusing on these nine
this is the basic clinical information
what i really want to highlight is that
through
traditional subgenetics either
karyotyping or fish
we know of six of these um
structural variants that are already
present that is a deletion of chromosome
seven in this sample
bcr able translocation in these two
samples the sample also has a deletion
of the y-chromosome
and this sample has a rearrangement of
the cbfp
gene on chromosome 16 which is a known
event
in aml and finally this one has a
deletion in chromosome 6.
what i really also want to point out is
that four of these samples are
considered normal
or negative by traditional cytogenetic
analysis
so traditional analysis will find
nothing wrong with these samples
even though they're obviously not normal
because they do have leukemia
so it was of interest to us to see what
could we find using optical genome
mapping
so this here on the left hand side is
the concordance between the traditional
karyotyping fish
cytogenetics and what was found by
optical genome mapping and
all of the events i described in the
previous slide were detected that is the
deletion of
chromosome 7 this pcr-able translocation
from chromosome 9 to 22 and these two
samples the deletion of the y chromosome
the inversion event on chromosome 16
and this deletion on chromosome 6. but
on the right hand side here what you can
see is that there are many many more
structural variants that were also
detected
even in the samples that were considered
normal by traditional cytogenetics
so we usually range from around 40 up to
as many as 80.
and all of these structural variants are
filtered against a database of healthy
volunteers
so none of these structural variants
have ever been found in a healthy
individual
these are all almost certainly involved
in the pathogenesis of the disease
itself
and the color scheme again is going to
be consistent throughout
we find mostly deletions and insertions
but we do find duplications
inversions and some translocations
this is just one example from one of our
relapse samples so we knew when this
patient first presented that they had
this deletion on chromosome 7 you can
see it here in the gene track
and we can also see many more deletions
across chromosome 7 which could well be
involved in the disease progression
but we also detected two translocations
that were not
found upon the initial presentation that
is this chromosome 2 to 11 translocation
and 5 to 11.
so this suggests that traditional
cytogenetics is not sensitive enough
sensitive enough to detect these or that
these translocations were present in a
very low clonal
population that has now taken over
suggesting that optical genome mapping
could also be used
for progression to track progression of
the disease
and then just one last example of a
circus plot
this is one of our samples that was
considered normal or negative by
traditional cytogenetics and we don't
see any translocations here
but we do see all the dots around here
the circus part represent
structural variants we found 13
insertions 37 deletions
an inversion and two duplications so a
lot more
structural variants detected using
optical genome map
and indeed one insertion event that we
detected in this sample
and insertion events i'm led to believe
are extremely hard to detect using
traditional
next generation sequencing methods but
here we find a 32
kilobase pair insertion in the middle of
a lysine methyl transferase 2ag
and this gene has been implicated in aml
before
so a sample that was considered normal
by cytogenetics we find this
potentially pathogenic insertion in a
known
disease-causing gene leukemia
so we do have 100 concordance but this
table here is supposed to show that
we've detected a lot more structural
variants
and we have manually curated what we've
found
to try and associate them with genes
that may be involved in cancer
progression
so you can scan along the gene list here
and find your favorite gene
but the real point of this is to show
that we detect all the different kinds
of structural variants
and the color scheme i'm using
throughout is going to be consistent
so what we find is we mostly detect
deletions and insertions
we also find duplications in versions
translocations
and just the two examples i'm going to
show at the top here bcr
able it's a translocation we find it in
two of our samples
but it's always the same thing example
we always bc are able it's always a
translocation
this here in cdk11a it's always a
deletion the two samples have it as a
deletion
similar here it's always the same so
these are probably just not random
events that we're detecting
these are probably true causative events
that are involved in the pathogenesis
of disease
so that is one of our data sets
structural variants but what we're also
interested in is differential chemical
sensitivity so all the samples that we
take
we screen them against 120 fda approved
uh oncology drugs and we
decide their uh viability so this here
shows the differential chemo sensitivity
that is we're only showing the drugs
that actually show sensitivities
different in at least one of our samples
i'm just gonna highlight
some of the drugs that i'm going to use
as examples later on
the bcl family inhibitors which are now
using leukemia the needle clax
is approved topoisomerase inhibitors
such stocks arubas and val rubison which
again as i said are frontline agents in
leukemia
another example i'm going to use is the
satniv or targeted
kinase inhibitors which are not used
right now in leukemia but are used in
other blood cancers
so this volcano plot here is the
integration of these
two diverse data sets so every spot in
this volcano plot represents a
structural variant
that occurs in at least two of our
samples that is associated with a change
in drug viability
that is in blue structural variants that
are associated with
resistance to the drugs in question and
in red
structural variants that are associated
with sensitivity to the drugs in
question
so as i said every spot here represents
one of those associations
but i've just highlighted a few here
that i'm going to give us specific
examples
in the next few slides but what this
shows is that there's a
wealth of information you can get from
these two diverse data sets once they're
overlapped
this is just another way of showing our
our top associations in this waterfall
plot here we see the top
five structural variant drug
associations that sensitize to the drugs
on the other side the top five
structural variants that are associated
with resistance
and as you can see is that pcr-able
translocations are involved in
sensitization to some drugs
but resistance to others so we chose
this pcr-abl
fusion as our proof of concept and these
are just the two
circus plots here at the bottom showing
this translocation from chromosome 22 to
9
in both samples and if you remember from
the start one of the samples also had a
deletion of the y chromosome and that's
marked here with the arrow
and the lower panel here is just the
genome level map
so we can see the optical genome map in
blue it's tracking along chromosome 9
perfectly until it gets to this break
point in the middle of the able gene and
then it maps back up again on chromosome
22 in the middle of bcr
and what we find is these two samples
when compared to our other seven are
much more
sensitive to the targeted kinase
inhibitors to satin melatonin
this is not a surprise because these
agents are known to target able
and similar kinases and in fact imatinib
or gleevec was actually designed as a
selective inhibitor of bc or able fusion
so this is not a surprise
but this is our proof of concept so what
this shows us is that we can
by using an unbiased manner we can
detect structural variants
we can detect drug sensitivities we can
overlay these and we can find
associations that we would expect
a lot of associations that we would not
expect
thankfully in this sample the bc are
able the two samples that are bcr able
translocation are more resistant to pcl2
family inhibitors
in this case an experimental agent
abt-737
but as i said other agents such as
venetoclax which target the same
proteins are now used for
leukemia patients so patients that do
have bcr-able translocations are less
likely to respond to this drug based on
our findings
and similarly with the proteosome
inhibitor carfilzonip it's not effective
against the samples with the bcr-abl
translocation but is effective against
the wild-type samples
another example is a gene called cdk11a
it's also known as cdc2l2 tumor
suppressor
and just one of the gene maps we're
showing here shows a rather large
deletion right across the body of the
cdk11a gene so this could indeed be
causative or involved in the
pathogenesis of this disease for these
patients
interestingly the two samples that do
have this deletion in the cdk11 gene
are more sensitive to the rubison family
of drugs doctor rubicon donors and val
rubison
these are all structural analogues and
as i said at the start donna rubicon is
a frontline agent
so although cdk11 may be pathogenic for
this disease
there is a good prognosis or potential
prognosis value for patients that
receive
donor medicine and just again an
unbiased association another indirect
dna damaging agent tinnitus side shows a
similar profile
and then one final example is a deletion
in a gene i had never heard of before
but again it shows the value of this
sort of unbiased analysis and detection
so the deletion in a gene called kif26b
this is a kinesin which is involved in
trafficking of cargoes along
microtubules
so it was gratifying to see that the two
samples that had a deletion in this
kinesin
were resistant to a microtubule
targeting agent paclitaxel
they're also resistant to mitomycin c
and triathylane melamine
and i'm not really going to discuss it
today but i'm just going to allude to it
we
also study other diseases other than
leukemia and in
three of our childhood brain cancers we
have also found a deletion in
kif26b or it's homolog kif26a
so in summary optical genome mapping
shows the 100 concordance with
traditional cytogenic analysis
but as i hope i have shown we don't just
find those six
major translocations and deletions that
we knew were there
we also find many many more and that
using these integrative analysis
we can associate these novel structural
variants with chemical sensitivities
and drug resistance to clinically
relevant agents
and all just by way quite your appetite
we don't just do this in leukemia we're
also analyzing glioblastomas
and childhood ependymomas and primary
cns lymphomas
and as i mentioned previously all three
of the appendaments we've screened
have shown deletions in chinese and
family members
and with that i would just like to thank
the four lad that sound for burning
previous
also junior and robbie murad from the
sovereign previous bioinformatics core
our collaborators jim mason and carol
borian who provide us with the leukemia
samples from
scripps md anderson and of course all
the team at bio nanogenomics
who were involved with analyzing the
first six of our samples
thank you thank you dr finlay
and these are great results and really
illustrate how
patient will benefit from optical
mapping whether it is to
an undefined classical rearrangement
informative for diagnostic procedure
but to profile tumors in precision
medicine thanks to our
ability to detect structural signature
and actionable fusion
and to also complement and modernize
the current standards of care to improve
patient management with a more
streamlined workflow that you can see on
this slide
[Music]
we're seeing a tremendous adoption all
over the world and
numerous studies are now evaluating
optical mapping against the standard
care
for cancer patients i would finish this
workshop with the results from
three users that nicely illustrate how
optical mapping can
modernize cytogenetics identify
clinically significant variants missed
by a standard care
and push the boundaries of precision
medicine
the first study is a multicentric study
led by
bryn levy from columbia university and
james brooks from penn state university
it is a landmark study where
optical mapping was uh compared against
the standard care
in a hundred aml cases previously
characterized by carotyping
fish and chromosomal microarray and not
only
by nano identified all the clinically
relevant variants
svs and cnvs reported by these
standard care but it also identified
additional variants in 11 of the cases
that have been missed by the routine
methods
so it showed the ability to uh identify
balance events like balance
translocation
that you can see here from the carry
type between
chromosome 10 and 13 and 8 and 21
that would be represented by these lines
over there
and between these chromosomes here
and there but also it showed the
potential to identify cryptic
events that were missed by karyotyping
in this example where a translocation
821 was
identified as you can see here but a
translocation between chromosome 4 and 5
was missed and was detected by optical
mapping with
a deletion of the five q
uh terminal region that can have a
significant impact
um to a stratified patient and to uh in
term of
risk assessments and since optical
mapping is a new technology
the authors modeled the optical mapping
nomenclature
on the array nomenclature described by
iscn
2016 but since macro technology cannot
detect balanced rearrangements they have
proposed a unique nomenclature
using this iscn logic that you can see
over there the conclusion
of their study is that besides
identifying
all clinically relevant svs and cnvs
reported by the combination of the
technologies that constitute their
standard of care
and reporting on additional svs
missed by routine methods optical
mapping
also refined the genomic structure
reported by traditional cytogenetics
and identify additional clinically
relevant variants
in about 24 of the cases and most
importantly in six percent of the cases
of a ml patient presenting a normal
karyotype
optical mapping directly identified
additional
clinically relevant variants and or cnvs
including fusion events so this has the
clear potential to improve the patient
management
in the future and optical mapping
identifies way more events
than classical cytogenetics because we
have a better resolution and we are not
targeted approached like fish but the
amount of data generated
isn't an impediment to an easy
characterization of cancer example
some structural variants translocations
for example
are considered hallmark for a risk
stratification of leukemia patients
and in a few clicks you can highlight
events
reported in international guidelines
published
for example by who or nccn
to do this you can simply create a panel
a virtual panel like
you have on this screen we call it the
bat file
that will extract from the genome-wide
interrogation of the genome all the
events
impacting the los say of interest that
you listed in this file
and of course this panel can be
customized at will
and combine to one another so in this
aml panel
you do have here reported 5q deletion
you can have a 7q deletion you have
any event impacting the kmt2 aging
any uh event impacting the the
translocation
h21 leading to a run x1 rx1 t1
fusion and also inversion on the
chromosome 16.
you can create this panel for any cancer
any pathology that you wish
we can make one for cll where besides
being able to assess the the complexity
of the karyotype directly from the
circus plot you can also directly
pinpoint any event impacting the genes
like
notch one bcl-2 that is uh
evaluated for patients to orient
the patient towards specific treatments
and also a deletion in the 17p
uh including the the tp53 gene over
there
but actually let me show you how it
works live
uh on a sample this is an all sample
where we loaded such that file that
follows some guidelines and uh include
gene lists reporting in those guidelines
and you can see
that uh comparatively to this previous
second clause
i i showed you you do have a an extra
circle over there
with blue bands and those bands are
actually the genes that i documented in
this uh
in this bed file if i zoom in one is run
x1 over there
this is um bcr but you can add any gnu
once
and so in these circles plots are
reported
the variants that uh have been
identified
in this sample and screen against our
control database to remove the
polymorphic variants that
are found in the normal population and
i simply have to go to this bed file
and decide to show only the svs and cnvs
that overlap with this gene list
and in just a few click and just a few
seconds
i will have just the filtering of this
genomic information
that will allow me to focus only on the
variants that are overlapping with genes
that are reported to be clinically
significant
in this in this cancer if i click on
this one
this is a deletion of the ebf1
gene so it's very easy
and we can see that the uh
identification of
hallmark virus is easy with the access
software
and while a lot of new clinically
relevant variants
are still identified and that well
completely unnoticed with the standard
care
because they were not expected and
because fish or panel sequencing
are targeted approaches and this leads
me to the second study from
children hospital los angeles where
dr gordon araka reported the
identification of variants missed by
standard methods and not identified by
their custom
gene panel since it was not expected in
this type of
leukemia and this illustrates the
importance of a genome-wide
unbiased structural variation detection
as provided by the sapphire
dr raqqa does genetic testing of
pediatric leukemia
at chla and routinely performs
a fish karyotyping chromosomal
microarray
and their oncokids ngs panel
and interestingly they routinely observe
about
15 percent of ball and five percent of
aml cases where the key genetic driver
remains unknown and eight of these
negative samples were run
on optical mapping to determine if it
can detect clinically significant
genetic drivers missed by their
comprehensive
molecular evaluation done on their
routine workflow
in two cases uh really stand out in
terms of discovery that i would like to
to develop a little bit uh this sample
is from a patient that had a
poor response to treatment and developed
a residual disease requiring
more aggressive treatments down the road
a translocation 2-5
was identified by karyotyping but at the
time of diagnostics
they did not really understand the
significance of such rearrangement
optical mapping found that the same
alteration
but could locate the breakpoint at a
much higher resolution
and an interesting gene was found
at the breakpoint of this translocation
the pdgfr
beta this uh
event was later of course confirmed
by fish and rna sequencing and the
pdgfr beta is associated with
what they call feel like all which is
linked to
high risk all and associated to a better
response to tyrosine kinase inhibitors
so this patient could have been treated
accordingly with
imatinib or designer nip if this
translocation was better characterized
at the time of diagnostic
and the uh interesting question is why
was it missed
in the first place well first of all
because the fusion of the
the pdgfr beta with this gene
uh sptbn1 has never been described in
bll before
but only in very few cases of another
hematological malignancy and hence it
wasn't
expected in this type of all and this is
why it was absence
from their oncoget panel
this second patient was also identified
as a standard risk patient and had a
even worse response to treatment than
the first one and had to be involved in
a carti trial
to get into remission and however
relapsed shortly after that
karyotyping seemed perfectly normal and
cma
didn't report abnormalities and to their
surprise when they
run optical mapping it reported numerous
rearrangements they were completely
unaware of and this is most likely due
to the fact that leukemia cells can
sometimes not grow or grow poorly
depending on the cultural condition and
this really illustrates the
potential of working from uncultured
cells with
optical mapping and here in this pretty
complex
circles plot a three-way rearrangement
between chromosome 1
6 and 12 leading to a fusion between
meth2d and fox g2 was undefined
meth2d fusions define a specific
sub-type
of bll and fox g2 is a very rare partner
described only once explaining why it
was not part of their ngs panel
and why was missed in their initial
comprehensive testing
and this fusion was confirmed by rna-seq
and the clinical significance is that
meth2d fusions
are associated with high-risk disease
and very poor outcome
explaining the aggressive cancer in this
patient
and that information would have been
crucial to risk stratifying
this patient
so it's striking too striking to see
the discoveries made in cancer sample
for which the standard care is already
focusing
on the identification of structural
variants and that really highlights the
importance of
applying optical mapping in solid tumors
cancer types where classical
cytogenetics is not applied
as it is in leukemia and where
structural variations
tends to be largely overlooked and dr
ravinda cooley from augusta university
evaluated optical mapping against a snip
array
that is part of the routine workflow in
brain tumors
among different samples included in the
pallet study
they observed a hundred percent
concordance with the snip array
uh like you can see on this on this
sample
so at the bottom you do have the onco
scan results
showing all the large gains and losses
at the define in the sample
and you can see how they perfectly
matched the results of the
by nano whole genome cnv plots that is
reported
on the top panel
but many other variants structural
variants
copy number variants many translocations
completely unsuspected
were found and many of them impacted
well-known oncogenes
or tumor suppressor genes like biraff
hgfr or a cdkn2a
and this is really illustrating the
importance of looking at those
structure variation and having these
genome-wide
analyses done at high coverage thanks to
optical mapping
so their conclusion is perfectly
concordant with the two previous studies
we saw with a clear potential of optical
mapping to identify
new unique genetic abnormalities new
fusions without any information on the
genes impacted
or the fusion partner needed think about
n-track fusions for which
dozens of fusion partners have been
described you clearly do not want to use
30 different fish probes here and also
to
the potential to improve um sv
characterization
in those complex karyotypes that have
been
shown by dr raka so the results are so
conclusive
that this study is on the path of a
laboratory a developed test for solid
tumor
at augusta university
so as a conclusion uh optical mapping is
a
is a long-range technology that
overcomes ngs limitation
and access regions of the genome
inaccessible
even to long-range sequencing because
it's
due to highly repetitive sequence
because these regions are flanked by
segmental duplications
or because they are composed of high gc
content
its coverage up to a 1600x coverage
can interrogate heterogeneous tissues
and allow the detection of structure
variants down to one percent
a little fraction automatically
genome-wide and for just a few hundred
dollars per sample
unlike rna sequencing it can detect
fusions
automatically and provide additional
information
on the mechanism leading to diffusion
events
even if this event is falling into
complex regions
such as the the igh locus that is
notoriously difficult to deal with by
rna sequencing
and this without any information on the
fusion partner
and of course it will also detect any uh
sv or cnv
affecting uh the regulatory sequencing
the sequences from the uh
the different evaluation uh we saw that
optical genome mapping can identify
classical rearrangements
informative for patient diagnostic on
risk stratification it shows outstanding
accordance with the standard care
but at a much higher resolution it can
identify actionable druggable events
without
a priori information often missed by
conventional workflows and you can also
reconstruct
complex structural signatures
automatically
without the need of a complex
bioinformatic pipeline to run
so i really hope all these applications
convince you to try our technology you
just have to flash the secure code to
access our website and get in touch with
our sales representative and we will be
happy to answer
any question you have in the chat or
by directly getting in touch with us on
this note
i will uh thank you for attention i
would like to thank again
dr finley for being with us today and
presenting
such outstanding results so
until next time goodbye